my Republican colleagues claim that the
border is open is the Border open Mr
secretary no it is not
thank you Mr secretary the border is not
open as you say having been asked this
over and over again uh that the United
States the president of the United
States the Secretary of Homeland
Security and all the hard-working men
and women at the border have operational
control as we Define that term
Congressman woman we do
we Define that term congresswoman it
depends on what the meaning of the word
is is it's all dissembling it's all a
bunch of Lies We Know 5.5 million people
at least have crossed the border since
Biden took office that doesn't include
the godaways so to try to save their
state and stem the flow of illegals and
drugs and everything else Texas took
matters into their own hands and
installed that floating buoy barrier
you've seen it in the Rio Grande well
since the Department of Justice the
entire Biden Administration wants an
open border of course they're suing
Texas joining us now is Texas lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick Dan just moments
ago the doj filed a preliminary
injunction in court asking the judge to
order Abbott Governor Abbott to remove
all the barriers until the final lawsuit
is decided in court your reaction
well people will die if that happens
Laura since we put up those buoys and
the concertina wire uh drowning deaths
just in that sector from October to
October last year 66 people drowned this
year 18. the El Paso sector last year 22
people drowned this year we're about two
or three because what we've done Laura
is spending our taxpayers money because
the Biden Administration is not doing
their job is we're forcing people to the
bridges so they're not Crossing anymore
Laura they're not trying to get across
the river because they can't get across
they can't get over the buoys and they
can't get through the wire so we've
stopped it and they want to go and sue
us so that Biden can hold the record as
seeing more people drowned on his watch
than any other president in history
well you know what I don't understand is
if they say basically the borders under
control why would they really even care
about the floating barrier like if no
one's coming or if it's under control
then why does the barrier matter
well every one except here's the White
House and Nadler
no better
yeah exactly here's what the White House
said yesterday Dan on this entire issue
watch
what you see the governor doing is
dangerous and unlawful it's actually
hurting the process it's hurting the
process of what we're trying to do
instead of coming to the table and
trying to figure out a way to work
together he continues to do this really
uh cool uh unjust and Humane ways of
moving forward
these people are the dumbest yeah
they're the dumbest people are that I've
I've ever seen in administration uh when
you see number one my orchest today and
he has his chin up in the air like
Mussolini you know that any body
language person will tell you when you
hold your chin up and talk to people
you're you know you're that's arrogant
you're trying to be uh Superior to
others you're really looking down at
others he looks down at everyone he
doesn't know Jack squat about what's
going on the border nothing this border
they do not have control Millions as you
said have crossed this border fentanyl
coming into our country criminals coming
into our country we alone large just our
law enforcement we've taken in over 400
million pounds of fentanyl enough to
kill every American that's just our
Troopers our national guard that we're
paying for uh We've apprehended over 30
000 hardened criminals across the border
we've apprehended over four hundred
thousand I'm just talking about our
people not to mention the millions that
they apprehend so what we're doing is
making sense we're stopping people
swimming across the river trying to get
these people are drowning and Biden
wants them to to continue to drown and
our country to be white yeah well here
and we appreciate it you're interfering
with their process all right their
process of having an open border that's
what you're interfering with Dan thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else